welcome to this video ykk junior
from turkey possibly at least it's a
turkish flag
okay let's see
okay um going for this this setup again
which has given me many good positions
really
here in online blitz
yeah knight to c7 it's it's surprising
how many people do that against this
kind of setup it's it's really
it's really uh completely wrong
just uh this is the only way to call it
it is
absolutely not right
because black has has no counter play
this is taking ages
to get uh get somewhere on the um
um on the queen side
um let's see yeah this is actually more
than one good way to play even bishop g5
is good
but i have a soft spot for this
bishop h6
let's see
yeah i can
yeah this is really
really nice now i can go f4 immediately
if i want
the direct way to play
like rook rook e1 then f4
okay let's let's um play play it very
straightforwardly
so um what about
yeah i mean okay let's just do this f5
directly
oh come on do you really need to drill
holes all day i have someone drilling
like a mad mania
in one of the neighboring apartments
okay so he's coming for before
bishop g5 i guess yeah just setting up
this pin
which is quite difficult to break this
is one reason why the knight is so
misplaced on c7
it's um
it's not lending any support to f6
hey really in in one second yeah
great
i really find this amazing what what
people can do i mean i cannot do that i
simply am too too bad for that
playing uh playing this kind of stuff in
one second
but okay
um let's see i can take g6 on
bishop f2 is also a move sorry knight f2
is also a move
probably i should take first
now okay if i go
knight f2
i can also play rook f8 and win the
queen yeah yeah why not actually check
let's do that
um and his rook is sort of hanging
okay i can check here bishop g7
uh maybe first this one here attacking
this rook
and set up for for rook f1
yeah i don't know look somewhere okay i
can yeah i probably just give the check
bishop g7 queen g6 and i don't see
any drawback
check no not really
yeah rook f1 next is my idea
and then trying to get get to the king
knight f6 still knight g4
um yeah bishop bishop h5 is also quite
good
or not wait bishop d7 you can maybe play
hmm
bishop d7
yeah well what just this
knight f4 and so on
yeah i'm falling asleep here i need to i
need to play a move
here you can actually give the check on
the form which i should have thought of
okay
check
yeah this is not so easy now
check him
one
yeah i really had forgotten about the
whole the whole thing
that that d4 was was possible
i hope it's still it's still winning but
i i have
screwed this up quite clearly
check
g6
what are you doing against this g6
nothing i guess
and it was it was probably still winning
but
yeah i should have
shouldn't have let this happen still
black resigns
yeah one thing is that really the knight
is not belonging to c7 against this it's
this opening it's really really bad
but okay it's it's questionable if this
is even good i mean i can
maybe bishop g5 is
is more interesting intending queen f4
it's it's possible that this is even
better
yeah i mean
yeah this is this is it's all it's all
very good
but
maybe um still bishop g5 is the is the
better way to play or this one here
and and again intending this i mean just
to give you an impression the computer
is on 1.3 and and stuff like that it's
like
really substantial
okay i went for this for the direct
attack now we're on plus two territory
and queen f4 is even stronger again okay
this this
and here i am okay i can take on g6 okay
this is even stronger
but
okay i couldn't i wouldn't couldn't
resist to just take this thing
yeah why is this better let's check
check
because of this this little idea okay
and here
check
here black is destroyed immediately okay
okay i went here
it takes
and uh yeah we're still on on plus two
yeah
right wins the queen m and
here the check
takes here
and i hear bishop f5 of course i was
bishop h5 i was
i had planned rook f1 but
and i thought okay this discovered check
but he has rook f4 which really
defends for a moment and again bishop h5
is winning why didn't i really think
about this
why didn't i do that bishop d7 was what
i was thinking
um ah rookie one
rookie one
not sure that i that i totally
understand it i mean of course
i'm winning by material already but
i'm not quite sure why
why this is so deadly
computer is on plus eight
now probably because knight e4 is also
coming
here
check
this this is not at all not at all
easy
he has this two uh two pawns which is
which is very dangerous
only only here after bishop f6
of course one of those instant moves
here white is again totally totally
winning
check
and here it's a mate
yeah it's this is really
really not a good good opening line
against the this setup all setups with
f3 and f4 and so on the knight is not
never
going to a6 but
you should always somehow put it put it
in this in this area
or play with h5 and so on the knight on
c7 is just just misplaced
okay thanks for watching